Android - Performance Patterns
We live in data hungry times.
Users want more data, more often, and are
spending more time searching for it.
As a developer of the
next great social application,
this might seem a perfect match
for your business plan.
But unless you construct your
networking requests the right way,
your business plan might be a huge flop.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And unknown to most developers,
each individual networking request
can have a load of performance
problems for their users.
At its core, networking performance
is about reducing the amount of time
between when the user wants data
and the networking returns it.
And there's a ton of things
that influence that variable,
for example, bandwidth latency,
cellular connection speed,
small mammals, apparently.
These are the typical things that users
know about, and generally understand,
when it comes to networking.
But there's also a second set
of performance concerns
that developers have to be aware of,
which are a little bit more pragmatic.
For example, using the cell radio
for networking is the number one killer
of battery performance for mobile devices.
And the more data you're transferring
results in costs and charges for users.
See, most of the time,
folks on limited bandwidth devices
don't appreciate you bringing down
2 gigabytes of image data
for your social media app.
In the end, it all boils down to two key
things that developers need to focus on.
Number one, reducing the amount of time
you keep the radio active.
And number two, reducing the size
of the data that you're fetching.
Now, lowering the request count
is actually a complex equation.
But for the sake of sanity, you can
generalize it into three primary buckets.
Firstly is the stuff the user asks to do.
So, like, update now.
Secondly is the stuff that the server
needs to update you about,
like a returning response
or letting you know that
there's new social data available.
And thirdly is the stuff that needs
to be uploaded frequently,
like uploading analytics,
or checking device location,
or something else that's interesting.
Now, the second two categories are really
the prime candidates for optimization.
For example, you should never, ever, ever,
poll the server regularly for updates.
You're basically just
wasting bandwidth and battery
for the server to tell you
that nothing's changed.
Instead, it's a better idea
to leverage other services
like Google Cloud Messaging,
which will let the server signal the app
when there's new content.
This will reduce the amount of battery
the phone uses as well as reduce
the overall number of server responses
that you need to worry about.
And for those situations where
cloud push can't be used,
it's critically important
to reduce the frequency
that those requests are made.
For example, rather than polling
the server every five seconds
asking for data,
try to use a backoff pattern
to reduce the number of requests
and get mostly the same results.
And rather than letting your requests
be strung out over time,
try to batch them together,
so they happen in short bursts
to optimize for an active cell radio,
which, will reduce battery waste.
And even try to think about
prefetching your data
so that you can reduce the need
for executing future requests
when you can do them now.
Now, stringing all of these
optimizations together is a sure fire way
to reduce the number of overall requests,
which will do wonders for battery life
and costs for your users.
And the good news is that you can
update your app to adopt these patterns
without having to write
a massive amount of code.
GCMNetworkManager is a
Google Play Services API,
which helps to schedule
network-oriented tasks
and handle batching for you.
This greatly simplifies the implementation
of common patterns,
such as waiting for network connectivity,
network retries, and exponential backoff,
basically all the good stuff you need
with a single, helpful API.
Now, of course, the second large
perf target is reducing the size
of the data in your request,
which, as far problems go,
is kind of a personal favorite of mine.
Let's see if we can get all of this
on one slide, shall we?
Firstly, watch the CompressorHead
series of videos so that you understand
more about data compression in general and
the algorithms that make up the science.
Then make sure you take the time
to read my article on image compression
and go through and be hyperaggressive
about the quality and format
of the images you're
sending from the servers.
Remember, smaller is always better.
Oh, and if you're a game developer,
then check out the "Texture Wranglin" talk
or the Crabby image format to get
some better results for ideal textures.
And once that's done, go back
and check out my "GZip is NOT enough" talk
to get a better understanding of
lossless compression for text-based data.
There's an article on that, too.
Followed, of course, by a hard, clear look
on how often you're sending around
XML and JSON packets,
which hopefully will depress you,
and you'll realize that you shouldn't
be sending around raw text data,
and instead, should be leveraging
Protobufs or FlatBuffers formats,
which I've got a video on that, too.
I talk a lot about compression.
Anyhow, if you're ever wondering how
your app is using or abusing the network,
make sure to spend
a lot of time getting familiar
with the networking tool
inside of Android Studio.
It'll show you how often
you make requests, their size,
and how long it took
to complete the round-trip.
If something's going wrong, this tool
is a first step in tracking it down.
But as we all know,
this is just the beginning.
For a deeper discussion
on any of the topics
I just rambled on about,
check out the rest
of the Android
Performance Patterns content.
And don't forget that there's
a whole horde of developers out there
solving the same perf problems as you.
So stop by the Google+ community
and ask for advice when you get stuck.
Anyhow, keep calm,
profile your code,
and always remember,
perf matters.
(music playing)